It's important to understand that we can't just pull the data with
Power Query and expect it to be perfect the way it is.
Getting the data also involve some tidying up.
So let's look at some common transformations that would help us do that.
Let's start with a simple example.
Here's the result we might typically expect to see when we
initially load a query before we've done any work to clean it up.
This query is coming in with no column names and in fact,
it looks like that first row has the data that should be used for the names.
Then there's a whole bunch of rows that are null,
and the name is just query
1 and here's what we want the data to look like when we're done tidying it up.
We want to give the query a logical name.
We want to remove any null rows and promote the first column to headers.
Most data sources will require some tidying to work in the data model even if
the structure that they come in as is working
perfectly to meet the needs for which they were designed.
For example, tracking marketing projects or sales
leads where there might be a lot of spacing added in for ease of use.
But making these transformations will make it easier for you,
your team, your report end users,
and for Power BI itself.
Let's start with tidying up for humans.
We want to talk about how you want to
experience your data when you load it into Power BI as a query.
Eventually queries also become tables and columns become fields.
When you're building a report at the end of this process,
you certainly don't want to have to remember that column 2
is actually the quantity column and that query 7 is your fact table.
Now, is the best time to give everything a logical name that you can easily
recognize and you'd be comfortable seeing on the final report.
Think of it from the perspective of someone who might take this over from you in a month.
You want them to be able to find things easily and make sense of how the queries work.
If only so they don't roll their eyes at how you built it.
We also want to tidy things up for the Power BI software.
As you continue to work with Power BI,
you'll find that the software really wants to anticipate your needs where it can,
and it's going to do the work for you if it's able to.
For this reason, it's just as important that you help Power BI
understand what you're trying to accomplish as it is for your human colleagues.
Two main ways we accomplish this are by removing rows and defining datatypes.
In both cases, we're cluing Power BI in on how
these fields should be treated according to Power BI's rules and logic.
Removing blank rows keeps Power BI from misinterpreting that we're
trying to use a nonexistent value in a key column, for example.
Giving every column the right datatype is also important.
This ensures that Power BI can sum, divide,
and perform various other calculations for a numeric column
and tells Power BI to turn the on time intelligence for a date column.